so we are now beginning to make our
complete study of rigid body motions
about fixed axis let's consider
something like a bicycle wheel here's
the center of mass of the wheel and our
bicycle wheel is the center of mass has
some velocity and here's ground and
we're gonna call this the reference
frame is the ground Frank now if the
bicycle wheel is rolling then there'll
be some type of rotational motion of the
wheel so you can imagine point on the
rim is rotating and so what we have here
is a angular velocity of this bicycle
which will write like this our vector
Omega and we'll use our right-hand rule
to establish that direction for Omega
and now in this reference frame we have
translational motion of the center of
mass and we have rotational motion
around the center of mass if we go to
the center of mass reference frame so if
you want them just a little cartoon to
show that here's your observer and your
observer is moving with BCM and so in
that frame the center of mass is at rest
and the only thing we have is rotation
about the center
of mass and so in this picture we we our
motivation will be that the total
external force causes the center of mass
to accelerate and that's how we can
figure out the center of mass motion and
in this picture we no longer have to
consider translational motion and what
we'll study and learn to analyze is just
pure rotation about the center of mass
so torque will produce angular
acceleration we can talk about the
rotational energy about the center of
mass and so we'll begin our analysis of
rotational motion of translation and
rotation by focusing our interest in the
center of mass frame so we've just
isolated the rotational motion